when he's not on the ice there an entirely
different team as you mentioned had knee
surgery for his ACL back in March this the first
nine games of this season right rocket in it pops
over barl and in and that's how Carolina scores
first [Music] tonight straight game in the lineup
he's going to start this in Center Ice where
he kind of jumps into the play The Punch just
flips up in the air and it bites when it hits
It's like a wedge that bites on the green watch
it bounce stop doesn't go anywhere and then
bounces over Roman Romanov stick well you can
see what varlamov does for the Islanders just
like sokin does when they in there go tending
is just so good oh off the iron and maybe a
piece of our Lama's glove one of the things
Carolina does why they defend so well as they
spend so much time in the offensive zone They
Tire you out you get the puck and all you can do
is change get it off the ice and change and Lee
with a nice pass to barel there and the centering
feet they score Bo Horvat how about that entry
into the Carolina Zone and terrific passing and
a scoring play with exactly two minutes left the
first the Islanders have tied it up they break
out of their Zone one of the few times cleanly
Anders Lee goes across the ice to Barelle and
when he pulls up he's looking for somebody to
find a scene barzel pushes the Carolina defense
deep you saw Burns was deep below the dot that
gave him enough room to wait for bu Horvat they're
not that far away from being a better team now can
they get there well we're going to find out they
still got three weeks or so to go without Adam
pelic and he's a big part of their team Martin
took the first shot and it's the second that's
scored Carolina the 2-1 [Music] lead scored
on opening night and he scores tonight this
is a nothing play but effort by martinook who
chips it and gets it himself he d throws it to
the net Anders Lee skats over top of the PT and
when he misses it this thing pops right out to
Jordan Stall slave and one touch to across spetch
nikov makes the pass in front and that is stopped
oh what a save on kutami maybe varlamov's best
save cinami all along of a slot penalty coming up
delayed penalty they don't have the one shot guy
they tried it last year with Pat Max pater ready
he tore his a Kill he tended twice Simon Holstrom
off the turnover he's dangerous has two short Ed
goals and he hits the crossbar in Simon holmstrom
shorthanded and that will tie him with Logan OK
Conor for the NHL lead Holstrom the early season
Sai Young Award winner candidate here that's six
goals and no assists as he intercepts the puck a
little Tic Tac given goal with JG a and Holstrom
comes in on the back hand this is a beauty up over
the shoulder and it's funny you know both goals
for Carolina have been the same in a game you feel
like you're up you know 4-1 or something like that
and you're all even barzel back handed around Ang
ball on it there for the island to the front they
score Pierre Ang ball has given the Islanders a 32
lead and if you thought Carolina was frustrated by
the short-handed goal how about now a puck battle
for this Puck as it goes up the board a little
stumble there allows barzel to get to the puck but
this is where Ang Bal wins the draw or wins the
puck battle from cot kenami and gets to the front
of the net now kotam is not in position to deny
the orov will pump it in deeper
Nate just pinned the boards there
Ang ball for the Islanders came over to
help Balo put his man down and a quick
score off the turnover back of the net 39
seconds in that's all it took and Carolina
has tied the game they've had a lead now in 18
to 22 games here they are tied up Carolina wins
a couple of board battles here this Puck has to
be delivered to a better spot and angal turns
it over and that's a great feed the effort from
behind the net from nus as he gets knocked over
he keeps it alive and Stephen n puts this right
on Jack Isles have 11 shots on goal in the game
in the game he said doson holds the Zone towards
the front of it that it's in pal Mary with a puck
in the crease back hands it in I'm not sure it
hit the back of the net even and it's a power
play goal for the Islanders have five shots in
27 minutes three of them have ended up in the
back of the net as PA Mar deflects this off
the doson shot there discussing here whether
they want to take a look at it I this one's not
going to be reviewable as well I mean anything
could be reviewable but the canes will look at
this look pretty clear the P Mar deflection is
stick was below the shoulders which it would
be not it wouldn't be the crossbar it would be
shoulders and here's the here's the call that
upon further review the call the ice stands
there is no high scking the puck we have a
goal Caroline assist bch minor penalty for
delay game failed challenge burns plays the
body and the puck stall one hands it away and
Carolina able to come out now got it across for
stall Lov turned around what a save and Carolina
looks to come out with some speed now NES can
do that KMI fires one off the iron to the left
of varlamov Isles can't lose another defenseman
snov got it shot sto RAR out shot that stopped the
crowd thought it was in Sebastian Alo wrapping
it around somehow barov got out there to make
a save rattled in off the glass goes behind the
net pulock will try to eat it in the corner AO
tried the center here's Burns shot block side of
the net or another save and it's in it's in while
Lov stopped the first one and couldn't stop the
second with 710 of a second remaining Carolina
has tied it four to four this is unbelievable
the Islanders trying to W or to wind the clock
down Le clearing attempt doesn't get up stall has
got a wide open net and he Mis cues on the puck
here it looks like aho JNS it in this
will be reviewed at the league for
sure right back is Brady Shay one on two
she's in to the forhead great save by Sean
Bava another great stop got it off for Jarvis
tried to make the pass broken up nicely by the
Islanders but look to counter barzel has got
horback here's barzel coming late gets the
return feed they score M Bell three assists and
one overtime goal to win it for New York 5 to
four were good some of them weren't he says
yeah I'm just trying to expand my game this
is what he's known for to transport the puck he
goes back it looks like it the place to Horvat
but he goes back to Dobson doson rolls it right
back to him and barzel does not miss the onetime
Beats ketov as you'll see barel look up there's
no play to wh about with the back checking Jarvis